did you lie at the dispatch box prime
minister
why didn't you try and stop sue grey
publishing her report prime minister
do you endorse law breaking in cabinet
pretty patel
is partygate embarrassing on the world
stage foreign secretary
are you being loyal to save your job do
you think a future prime minister would
make you foreign secretary do you want
to replace boris johnson
would you defend anything at all grant
chaps
simon clark why did you get the facts
wrong yesterday over the sue grey report
meeting
are you embarrassed by getting the facts
wrong
does partygate enhance this government's
reputation sowella
good morning to you
did you discuss partygate in cabinet
deputy prime minister
has boris johnson got a better grip on
the on government than you had on the
foreign office last year
did boris johnson lie at the dispatch
box nadine zahawi or would you prefer to
succeed him as prime minister
did you talk about party gate in cabinet
or is it easier to hear no evil and see
no evil
i bet there are
right um that was what was happening
outside downing street this morning more
questions should we say then answers
let's speak to our political
correspondent liz bates because we may
soon have some answers the sioux gray
report we understand may be
tomorrow
uh yeah that's what we um think at the
moment so not expecting the sue grey
report today possibly tomorrow uh
as you said um our deputy political
editor sam coats they're putting those
questions to cabinet ministers very uh
forcefully and not really getting any
answers we were told um that sue gray
and the daniel street parties were not
discussed uh this morning in cabinet
well if that is the case then the
cabinet are the only people that aren't
speaking about this issue um in
westminster what we think will happen
though when we finally get the sue grey
report uh if that does happen tomorrow
we will hear from the prime minister
first of all he's expected to give a
statement to mps in parliament he will
also face his own conservative mps at a
meeting of the
1922 uh committee we also understand
that there may be a press conference as
well so sort of series of apologies um
if you like at that point we do hope to
get some more answers clarity on the
questions that have been raised uh over
the past uh 24 hours since this picture
emerged of a gathering on november the
13th 2020 one of the um
the big questions that has been raised
of course is the metropolitan police's
decision to
we think uh fine one person at that
gathering but maybe not others and
and not the prime minister and there has
been mounting pressure now on the
metropolitan police to explain their
reasoning for that provide more clarity
and transparency and one of those people
that has been calling for that is the
mayor of london sadiq khan
i am asking the met police to provide
the urgent clarity i think they've got
to provide not simply because you're
asking the question but people across
the country not unreasonably will be
saying hold on a second
i followed all the rules i was
meticulous in relation to following the
rules those that broke the rules were
fined and here we have a photograph
which looks like the prime minister
caught red-handed at breaking
the rules some would call it
a smoking gun so the police should
explain
how it is that more fines weren't issued
well number 10 say that that is an issue
for the metropolitan police lots more
questions though
for number 10 today one of those is on
this meeting that took place between the
prime minister and su grey the latest
suggestion on that was that the prime
minister
maybe
said to sue gray during that meeting
that she may not even want to release
this full report at all because a lot of
the information
is already in the public domain well
number 10 pushed back quite strongly on
that today they said that the prime
minister in no way put pressure on her
to drop the report and in fact he wants
the report to be published in full in
terms of questions um on that picture um
lots of those put to number 10 as well
did the prime minister believe that he
was at a party or a work event when he
wandered into that room why didn't he
stop it and of course his crucial issue
of did he mislead parliament over this
gathering because he was asked by a
labour mp at catherine west
about this gathering and he said that
all the rules
were followed well the answer that we
got again and again was you need to wait
for the sue grey report and at that
point the prime minister will give his
response in full so we find ourselves
once again months after this report
started waiting for sugree